We have at the end of the show.
Boba Fett came out.
And it said The Book of Boba Fett coming Christmas,
I'm sorry, coming December of 2021.
And that wasn't part of the big disney announcement.
But here's the logo, we wanted to hold this
back, because we didn't want to spoil the
surprise during the big Disney Announcement
of all the shows.
So they let me keep this one a secret.
So this is actually separate from the mandalorian
season 3.
But what we didn't say in that announcement
is that the next show coming up.
Kathy said the next chapter.
And that's going to be the Book of Boba Fett.
And then we go into production right after
that on Season 3 of the mandalorian.
Back with the main character that we all have
known and loved.
So that's going to be pretty soon following
that.
So we're working on that preproduction now
while we work on Boba Fett.
Are there more spinoffs we can expect from
the mandalorian.
Yes, we'll there's a lot of star wars content
coming out.
As I think they announced 10 projects, I think
this would be 11.
With the new Book of Boba Fett.
But the ones that I'm involved with are.
I'm working with my partner Dave Filoni, who
is this fantastic producing writing partner.
Who I met when I did a voice in the Clone
Wars.
We met up at the Skywalker Ranch and we were
working on this show.
He's doing Ahsoka.
Which he's writing right now.
And then we also have the rangers of the new
republic.
And all of them take place in the similar
timeline here.
That is right after Return of The Jedi.
Which was a film of course, we all grew up
with.
I was actually an usher in the movie theater.
Back in Queens.
The RKO Keith's.
When Return of the Jedi was playing.
So I saw that movie dozens and dozens of times
at work.
And now it's so fun to be continuing the story
after that.
With those characters.
Luke Skywalker, one of the most iconic heroes
in history.
Mark Hamill making a comeback in the season
finale there.
What went into that decision.
There was a risk in doing that.
And how did you keep that under wraps?
It was very tricky.
Because it's very hard to keep a secret nowadays.
Especially with star wars.
Because people are so curious about it.
And there are so many people involved with
the process.
The special effects, finishing it, making
it, filming it.
The studios, everything.
And every leak, every piece of casting leaked.
And we were so scared right up till it aired
that our surprise cameo was going to leak too.
But we started off the whole series with the
baby yoda reveal.
With the grogu reveal.
That was a secret that everybody was really
blown away by.
And part of that is not telling too many people.
Not having merchandise that's being tooled
up.
And annouced all that kid of thing.
And then to have the very last episode.
To have mark hamill actually on set, filming
and us using whatever technology we had available
to de-age him and try to make him look as
much like he did in the old films.
It was an exciting moment.
I have to ask you quickly though.
Because we're running out of time here.
Grogu?
Where did that name come from, Grogu.
I had written it in the script from very early
on.
And we finally revealed it in the show.
But of course everyone knows Grogu as Baby
Yoda.
Which by the way, is fine with all of us.
We still call him baby yoda too.
But he prefers to be called Grogu.
If you noticed in the show, he perks up a
lot when they say his name.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie.
This is going to be my new Mandalorian video
Obviously explaining what's going on with
the book of Boba Fett miniseries that Jon
Favreau just explained there the teaser trailer
at the end of the Mandalorian season 2 finale.
We finally have all the details.
So we'll break it down.
If you're brand-new to the channel.
Be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes
I will be doing bonus videos for the Mandalorian
season 3 and the Boba Fett series all the
other Star Wars series that they announce
obvious he is going to be a lot of Star Wars
the next couple of years Jon Favreau said
that they have 11 new series coming with this
Boba Fett announcement.
I'm really excited about all this.
Jon Favreau Dave Filoni very clearly have
a handle on the future of Star Wars and the
future of Star Wars really is in these Star
Wars series that they're doing not so much
in the movies like you would normally expect,
but careful for spoilers for everything that
happened on the Mandalorian.
So far just because that's obviously a big
part of what he was talking about and the
events of the Boba Fett series.
He confirmed that the book of Boba Fett is
a full separate spinoff show from the Mandalorian
Robert Rodriguez will be doing it with him
and Dave Filoni, so obviously he directed
the Boba Fett episode season 2 episode six.
It makes sense now why he did that because
they seem like a trial run for the Boba Fett
miniseries.
Jon Favreau also clarified that he's mostly
involved with the Mandalorian spinoff series.
Out of the 10, now 11 Star Wars shows that
they announce even though there all kind of
working together using the same technology
and those special video walls.
He confirmed that the Boba Fett episodes will
start releasing in December 2021, and he said
Christmas first, but then he backtracked really
quickly and said I mean December and the Mandalorian
season 3 will premiere shortly after the Boba
Fett episodes are all done.
There filming the Boba Fett episodes right
now as me posting this video.
And right after they finished those the start
filming the Mandalorian season 3 episodes,
so when he said that the Mandalorian season
3 would start right after they're done what
he means is if the going to start filming
that after they're done filming the Boba Fett
series then will actually release the Mandalorian
season 3 episodes after the Boba Fett episodes
are done releasing so that means that the
Mandalorian season 3 will release in the early
part of 2022, when he said that the Mandalorian
season 3 will focus on the character that
we all know and love obvious he he's talking
about Pedro Pascal's man dough character,
he still the main character.
Even though it seems like everyone kinda went
their separate ways and Bo Katan is becoming
a much bigger deal with the other Mandalorian
characters Grogu is off Luke Skywalker for
his Jedi training montage of Grogu is obvious
he still going to be a big part of the Mandalorian
season 3.
He just won't be riding around in Mandos hip
pocket for a while and I think the going to
find a way to avoid having to use Luke Skywalker
a lot on screen, because the way he talks
about the Luke Skywalker cameo scene in the
finale.
It was meant to be a really really special
thing not something that the going to do every
single episode.
He didn't say how many episodes of the book
of Boba Fett they're going to be, but when
they're calling it a miniseries that means
it just a one off-season probably shorter
episode count than the Mandalorian main series
to maybe like 4 to 6 episodes.
The probably wait to reveal that until they
have an actual trailer that they released
later next year, but the book of Boba Fett
series will be set mostly on and around tattooing
and job as criminal empire, I did a video
for the post credit scene, a couple days ago
a link in the description, but during that
I made a reference to that classic book tales
from job as palace.
If you read those classic legends books they
just delve more into the side characters and
stories behind all the people that show up
a job as palace the bounty hunters the scoundrels
so we'll be seeing more of that side of the
Star Wars universe.
During the Boba Fett episodes also really
big deal.
He confirmed that Dave Filoni is currently
writing all of the Star Wars Ahsoka Tano series
episodes.
So if you were worried whether or not Dave
Filoni was going to be involved with that
is, is that he's personally going to be handling
most of the really big important stuff for
that series which affiliate is the best possible
scenario, but now we have for Mandalorian
based shows you can call it the MCU the Mandalorian
cinematic universe which is funny because
Jon Favreau helped give birth to the Marvel
cinematic universe with the first Ironman
filming Kevin Feige.
So I'm sure Kevin Feige is watching all this
just as happy as we are.
If you guys don't remember a while ago they
announce the Kevin Feige would be producing
a Star Wars movie.
Eventually, but they didn't say when that
was going to happen and he so busy getting
Marvel phase for Marvel phase 5 and all the
X-Men fantastic for stuff off the ground that
will probably not going to see whatever his
Star Wars movies going to be for several years,
but even though kind of sucks that.
There's a small delay before we get Mandalorian
season 3 episodes normally you would expect
them around this time next year.
The main reason why they didn't start filming
season 3 sooner is mostly just because of
how the virus delayed everything a little
and apparently Pedro Pascal is filming a small
movie right now and they let him go off to
do that while they film the Boba Fett series
between the Mandalorian season 2 and season
3 and the timeline.
So what he's saying during this though, is
that the events of the Mandalorian season
3 episode one will pick up after the book
of Boba Fett, like the book of Boba Fett is
meant to fit in between Mandalorian season
2 and season 3 that confirms my theory about
the small time jump between man dough season
2 and season 3.
There a lot of reasons why you do a time jump
like that and a lot of them involve leveling
up Grogu's Jedi powers with Luke Skywalker
is fast as possible, but just in terms of
when all these episodes are coming.
If the Boba Fett episodes start releasing
the week of Christmas 2021, and it run for
at least for episodes.
They might be able to release Mandalorian
season 3 by at least March 2022.
Hopefully a little bit sooner than that, but
I will be doing Boba Fett videos and Mandalorian
season 3 bonus videos during the off-season
for any the big announcements are castings
obviously were expecting a lot more animated
characters to come in and a lot more throng
trilogy Easter eggs.
My next video will be a bigger Luke Skywalker
video about what's going on with him and how
they're using him now in the Mandalorian cinematic
universe and all the series and was going
on with the other Jedi.
There still a lot of other big Jedi characters
that they need to introduce and legends characters
from the throng trilogy that they can also
bring back like Mara Jade is a really good
example that video should post later tonight.
So make sure you have alerts enabled for my
channel so you don't miss it, but everyone
click here for my new Mandalorian season 3
top 10 video and click here for my full Mandalorian
season 2 episode eight finale video think
you so much for watching everyone stay safe
this is the way!